東京のど真ん中から今日は今週もガンガンのスケジュールでほぼほぼ東京なんですけど
もなんとか道を出しております肇社長で動画編集というものをほぼ毎日僕やってるん
ですけども結構ねもう動画編集って何かね
誰でもできると思うんですよねもう小学生ユーチューバーとは中学生宇宙ばもいるわけ
ですから大抵の軟化を大人の方とかあなたは家紋とが学生さんとかはたぶん
練習を何とかすればできると思うんですよね私そんな動画編集をするような職業っぽい
ユーチューバー的な絵って一応あの日本一米ながら同編集そんなすごいことができる
わけじゃないんですけども多少なりとも同編集にある程度でパッソのなんか爺っていう
かあの技術的なっていう間加工才能みたいなものは多少あると思うんですけどもこの
ままが満足していた
だめだなと思うんですよある程度の技術とか知識があるんですけどもそんなんだけだと
またまた上には登れない僕はまだまだ進化できると思っているので今の編集で満足して
いるようじゃまだダメなんですよてで今日はですねちょっとねぼく編集の勉強をしよう
と思いまして編集技術って一概にこう色んなのがあると思うんですよなんか3 d の
編集する人がいたりーな
炎を出す編集する人がいたりアニメーションを作る人がいたり面白い編集をする人がい
たりテキストを出さにする人もいたりいろんな編集の方法があると思うんですけども
あの僕は他人の人の編集をすごい今見てみたいなと思ってなんかやっぱ他の人が必須
って僕すらないことが多いんですよ
そこから
得られるものってすごい多いと思いまして今回はですねあの皆さんの編集と
を見たいと思っておりますまあ何をするかと言いますとの箱皆さんの参加型動画的な奴
なんですけどもう僕が1本の動画をみなさんにお渡しします
雨具級の動画見てるもんみんなですからねみんなもうそこのみんな動画編集できそうな
のがスマホ
スマホはきついかなパソコン農外のしないね動画編集ちょっと手をしたことあるような
あって人にあの今から1本の動画をみなさんにお渡しするのでそれをちょっともう
なんか何でもいいですとりあえず会編集して姉みたいと思っております
名付けてはじめ車窓の動画まあ改造たいかー
もう今言ったとおりでございます同じ素材でもいろんな人がいるわけですからいろんな
編集の方法があるでその素材がどう変わるかを僕楽しみたいな
勉強したいなと思いまして皆さんに1本の集いを渡してそれを編集して僕に渡して
もらいますで東風それの鑑賞会をしようと思いますのであのね皆さんお楽しみにしてい
てください
そのようですね
シンプルのほうがいいなと思いましてこちらを準備しましたどうぞ
お前の
崩した
ああ
うぇい
[音楽]
つまらないでしょっつまんないと思うでしょでもねつまんない道の一環に面白くするか
力の見せ所だと思うんですよ
私はですね町ル0というかこんな感じもできるよっていうのを一応作っておいたんで
あの参考までにご覧下さい
どうぞ
mar
dare
par
あああああいいいい
re
俺
[音楽]
はいこれ作るのに僕だいたい30分もかからないくらいかな
それぐらいであの作ってみましたあの結構やっつけ仕事なところもあるんですけども
やったねー
あの音楽のリズムに合わせる兄弟ば面白いと思うんですよねまあこの方向性をどんどん
詰めていけばもっと面白くなると思うんですけどもあのぜひいろんな方の動画編集の力
を見たいと思っております技術なりひらめきな
リアのぜひ見せてくださいよろしくお願いします素材のダウンロードはどんなの概要欄
から何撮っていきますぜひダウンロードして編集してください
あのあー次長言っときますけどあ今日記事ですからねこの動画のためにだけに使って
くださいで応募の方法なんですけども編集てきた動画をですね x チューブに限定
公開てあげてくださいでその限定公開車動画の言う
url とあの編集してくださったあのあなたのお名前を書いて
動画のだよ欄である応募フォームから応募できますのでぜひ応募してみてください
あなたの作品が僕の動画で発表されるかもしれません
フィギュアの発表会ででるってことですね著作権とかあるって
書作系フリーとかクレジット表記のいらないフリーの音楽トム画像とか素材でどう
がおつくってくださいバレバレじゃ削減ひっかくなんか j-pop と扱っていると
動画にすら使われないんであの
そんな悲しいことはないようにご了承お願いしますあのどれくらいの応募があるか
分からないんですけどもあ是非とも色んな編集を見てのサラダの自分の成長につなげ
たいと思いますので
皆さん動画編集の方よろしくお願い致しますあの結構楽しみですあの
編集無限の可能性があると思っているのであの楽しみに待っております
以上データに1週間ほど待とうと思っております6月1日までにしましょう6月1日の
23時59分まで
応募をお待ちしております動画編集できる方是非視聴してください
編集できる
方も発表会あの楽しみにして下さいいろんな編集が見れると思います
じゃあ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ